I got the latest Olympic update you
probably want this right yeah and like
the Olympics this show was taped fifteen
hours ago at a pool so don't tweet the
results okay I was kind of okay now I
got the latest update about the Olympics
so far China has won the most gold
medals wait at the government yeah yeah
the Chinese athletes can't wait to get
home and show the medals off to the kids
who made them
very much you've heard about this
problem right Olympic organizers are
reportedly struggling to fill rows and
rows of empty seats empty seats yeah in
fact yesterday officials put out a
casting call asking for 200 Europeans or
eight Americans michael phelps has been
struggling a little bit yes
yeah thanks Andy that's improv training
yeah
yes my boss yeah ring is that like I
went to like some sort of Lackey
technically yes
now some people were saying that the
reason Michael Phelps isn't doing so
well is because he let himself get too
out of shape yeah I just have to say
I've been watching the Olympics if that
guy is out of shape
I've been dead for five years thinking
could I go loan who are oh wait he's got
two percent body fat I know hey guys a
slob
although together man
all those swimmers have inspired me I
have started shaving my entire body
[Applause]
but unfortunately manchild that I am it
didn't take no one a stripe rice a
Chinese strip that why get into it John
there's really no reason to they're
having some technical trouble at the
Olympics Olympic officials said that
attendees are tweeting so much it's
crashing their mobile network now
apparently it's due to all the teenage
girls with Al Michaels fever a silence
you don't hear in deep space you know
there's just different gradations you
have to understand that joke didn't even
medal it was
that was incredible right give me that
joke I want to give that away to someone
in the crowd
[Applause]
[Music]
hope you have better luck with that
thing than I did
[Laughter]
good god that was quiet me
maybe I'll Michael's fever is a real
yeah
people just don't find it funny I don't
know they don't know who he is
hey or do and just don't like it who
knows I do a volume business Hey
Mitt Romney caused quite the controversy
the Olympics you follow this right
Mitt Romney campaign still trying to do
damage control after remarks that Romney
made while in the UK probably Romney's
worst gaffe was when he visited
Buckingham Palace and said to Queen
Elizabeth you call this a house of
course Romney's in Israel now did you
know that yeah over the weekend Mitt
Romney was in Jerusalem and he slipped a
prayer into a crack in the Wailing Wall
yeah and while he was at it he also
stuffed in three million dollars of
taxable income
then he came down with Al Michaels fever
thanks only friend left in the studio
audience